you're the guy I talked to yeah man a
lot of [ __ ] talking compute a lot of
[ __ ] talking things we probably
shouldn't say luckily it doesn't make
the broadcast well when that one got
leaked
when Aldo was about to fight Connor and
I said he does not look good I said he
looks nervous as [ __ ] everyone's body
looks flat often flat yeah and then he
got flatlined
yeah well yeah you were right I was
right in that regard that did make
program didn't it well people what
happened was somebody recorded it as I
was talking to you I think and I was
talking to Bruce and it just somebody
just decided to be a little [ __ ] dude
that [ __ ] I know it in that truck
sometimes have to be wrong [ __ ]
button and I'm gonna be talking [ __ ] to
you or meirin or something well that was
one where was it was interesting I was
like oh okay well somebody's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you're you're privy to this
sort of inside banter to like to release
that like and make it public I would
never say that publicly so I was very
upset that they did that yeah but it was
honest no you're right it was honest he
did look like [ __ ]
but damn he looked good last weekend he
looked unbelievable that crazy man I
liked asking for I love Jeremy Stephens
great guy I mean you know what we're
cool with everybody
yeah work for the company or got to get
to know everybody got to be cool to
everybody but it was good to see you
Jose Aldo back on top man he needed that
bad well when someone always happen when
someone live wins with a liver shot oh
because it's such a it's one of those
weird punches like you'll see someone
you'll see two guys and they exchange
good shots to the body and they seem
like they have no effect you know
obviously they hurt but they'll deal
with it and keep fighting and then every
now and then you see whap you see that
liver shot where the legs go out the
body gives in is like man that is crazy
that we have this one area that
sometimes works you know because
sometimes doesn't work right that's
right a liver shots weird man and it's
delayed that's the funniest part about
it there's like a split second delay way
like I got this
just fold over if you saw that to like
there was a body shot that that he threw
he threw like a rewrite hand to the body
and then the left lever shot so I think
it's kind of like you know you take the
first punch and then you brace and you
got it and then you relax for a second
and that's when the diaphragm and you
live us that's a vibrating I wish it
made sense well I heard is right here
I could see it again great video yeah
well she throws the right hand to the
body first there it isn't there this
double body shot yeah in Jeremy's a bang
a two man that's a tough dude man to get
dropped from a body shot and to make
that face too you can't have it so bad
well Kevin Ross is the only guy that
I've ever seen hide it Kevin Ross got he
was fighting in Bellator not his last
fight but maybe the previous fight and
he got hit in the first round with a
spinning back kick right in the liver
and he just probably just yeah see just
kept moving and he said he was in
ultimate agony absolutely but he didn't
show [ __ ] and his opponent didn't know I
mean he really pulled it off you've
really pulled it off he figured out how
to just